ich weiß nicht was mit euch los ist ihr
wollt wirklich unbedingt dass ich den
marame Adventskalender auspacke und
wisst ihr was der kostet ausnahmsweise
mal nur 40 € mein Gott das ist ja quasi
geschenkt und jetzt h ich mal auf mit
dem Mikro in der Hand hier schei zu
labern Kinder hören mir
zu reiert ins Blaue Haus hallo liebe
Kinder hier ist eure malwanne ich habe
schon gehört dass da ganz viele von euch
meine Videos gucken und ich freue mich
tierisch darüber könnt ihr mir nur einen
Gefallen tun eure Eltern bleiben
weiterhin euer Vorbild okay ich bin nur
so eine lustige Person aus dem Internet
die man nicht zu ernst nehmen sollte und
jetzt geht's los mit dem Video los
geht's los geht's mein Gott ich wäre so
gern eine TOGGO Moderatorin oder
Kinderkanal aber die haben sich noch nie
gemeldet also vielleicht war das jetzt
meine offizielle Bewerbung ich habe
Erfahrung vor der Kamera und ich habe
Erfahrung mit Kinder ich habe ich habe
viele Praktiker in Kindergärten gemacht
und ich habe in Schulen gearbeitet bevor
ich youtube Star wurde das heißt das
passt gut zusammen oh mein Gott ich bin
so Jeny ich bin so Jeny cringe ich
möchte e aber wirklich noch mal vorher
sagen vielen Dank für euren Support ich
habe schon gesehen ganz viele Leute
haben mich abonniert ihr seid spitze und
vielleicht schaffe ich es ja dieses Jahr
noch eine Million Abonnenten zu bekommen
wie gesagt ihr dürft nächstes Jahr dann
wieder nicht abonnieren denn 57% die
meine Videos schauen abonnieren mich
nicht wollen wir mal drüber sprechen was
ist da los was gebe ich euch
nicht 24 liebevolle Projekte zum selber
machen inklusiv Makram und G ja gut also
das sollte ja wohl drin sein ich habe
noch nie vorher Makram gemacht ich hoffe
ich kriege das hin ich habe auch das
Gefühl dieser advskalender oh oh
Mist also hier ist das Anleitungsbuch so
und so lernen wir dann jeden Tag makrame
oh gibt wirklich 24 Projekte und wir
fangen an mit Türchen Nummer 16 Spaß
Nummer
1 packen wir es mal aus in Türchen
Nummer 1 ist
natürlich Seil drin okay und was sollen
wir damit machen ich habe kein Holzstab
die hat ein Holzstab ein Holzlöffel das
ist mein Holzlöffel grundlegende Knoten
wir lernen jetzt den
ankerknoten ich sag da jetzt gar nichts
ihr wolltet das sehen jetzt kriegt ihr
euer makrame die beiden Enden eines
Fadens zusammenlegen und die dabei
entstehende Schlinge von oben hinten den
Holzstab führen ich hätte mir ein
häkelkalender holen sollen ach klar
diesen Knoten kenne ich doch das ist der
klassische der ganz klassische so
wickeln und dann zack ich habe marrame
gemacht und dann noch mal also laut
Anleitung hier so runter und der dann
von unten drunter und dann so
zusammenziehen ich kriege das nicht hin
alle die jetzt schon voll lange makrame
sagen ja das ist ja auch das muss man
erst mal lernen ah und wenn das dann da
drüber war kommt das hier drunter das
ist schwer drüber drunter durch die
Schlaufe durch sieht richtig hübsch aus
werde ich noch ein marame Fan auf meine
alten Tage und hier habt ihr meinen
ersten wellenförmigen marameanhänger den
packe ich euch natürlich auch in die
verlosungsbox ich möchte h aber noch so
viel mehr
entdecken Türchen Nummer
2 ich glaube ich muss spaßer mit dem
Seil sein ich nur so ein großer Ring und
drei Holzkugeln drin und damit sollen
wir das hier basteln oh mein Gott ich
habe ganz vergessen zu sagen dieses
Video ist gesponsert von Lal Laab und
genauso schnell wie ich meine Outfits
wechseln kann kann euch die App Lal Laab
eure Fotos in Windeseile zuschicken Lal
Laab ist eine App mit der ihr direkt von
eurem Handy eure Fotos hochladen könnt
und die Auswahl was ihr alles damit
drucken könnt ist riesig letztes Jahr
habe ich Geschenke für Annie und meine
Schwiegereltern ausgedruckt und dieses
Jahr ist Naomi dran wenn ihr das hier
jetzt seht dann dürft ihr Naomi bitte
nichts verraten ich weiß nämlich noch
nicht genau wann ich ihr das schenken
werde aber ich bin ein bisschen
ausgeflippt eine Fotobox habe ich für
mich erstellt und in dieser Fotobox sind
die Bilder von meinem Geburtstag und da
ist meine Schwester und mein Schwager
und da bin ich mit einem Cocktail in der
Hand und wieder ich mit einem tollen
Outfit letztes Jahr bekam einin
Schwiegerpapa Magnete dieses Jahr
bekommt Naomi welche und ich hatte die
beste Idee überhaupt ich liebe Naomis
looks aus den Musikvideos und sie postet
die immer auf Instagram und ich habe das
Set einfach doppelt bestellt und jetzt
denkt ihr doppelt
damit sie das als memory benutzen kann
und mit ihrem een Gesicht Memory spielen
kann gut vielleicht schenkt sie das an
ihre Mama weiter oder so das wä schon
sehr narzisstisch wenn Sie mit Ihrem
eigenen Gesicht memory spielt aber sorry
diese Fotos eignen sich so gut davon
Memory zu machen schaut euch mal die
Qualität an das ist ein Screenshot das
ist nicht mal ich hatte nicht mal das
Originalfoto Screenshot ja das ist das
kleine Spiel was sie bekommt dann kann
man natürlich auch klassische Fotobücher
machen in verschiedenen Größen hier habe
ich einfach mit der notipp das hier
geschrieben und das als Titelbild
genommen fand ich irgendwie total cool
einfach auch wieder ein Screenshot davon
genommen und die Fotos von ihrer Tour in
Hamburg und Berlin habe ich von Timo
bekommen weil er ihr tourfotograf und
Videograf war und jetzt hat sie so ein
kleines Buch von der Tour dann gibt's
auch noch so Fototaschen total hübsch
habe mich an Naomi erinnert das Design
und da kann man auch richtig viele Fotos
aussuchen die habe ich jetzt in matt
ausgesucht auch wieder voll viele von
ihren looks weil ich dachte wenn sie z.B
so ein neues Musikvideo plant und so ein
moodboard sich erstellen möchte zack
hast du ein Foto fürs moodboard kann sie
sagen diesen Look fand ich cool und den
und vielleicht können wir was in diese
Richtung machen oder sie benutzt als
Autogrammkarte und ich habe noch Fotos
von der Tour ausgedruckt es hört aber
noch nicht auf ich weiß nicht was Naomi
sagen wird ich glaube das ist mein
Favorite Jahreskalender Naomis Looks in
Sternzeichen Naomi hat so viele
verschiedene Looks dass mich einige an
Sternzeichen erinnert haben hier ganz
klar Fische und im August Löwe sind
einfach Screenshots ich kann es nicht
glauben und weil das ja noch nicht genug
wäre gibt's auch noch zwei Bilder man
kann sich bei Lal Lab halt selber so
Texte überlegen und da habe ich ihre
Songs drauf gemacht und ein Foto was ich
so schön fand von Ihro sie am Wein ist
und du kannst sich das Aufhängen ihr
seht man kann total kreativ werden und
mit meinem Rabattcode malw 30 könnt ihr
sogar bis zum 31.12 30% sparen und alle
Infos bekommt ihr dazu noch weiter in
der Infobox und jetzt geht's weiter mit
dem Video ich wollte so gechillt sein
Okay die Frage ist nur da wird immer
nicht erklärt Baumwollfaden Natur aus
Box 1 4 x 45 cm lang jetzt brauche ich
Lineal so meine Damen
Herren ein stockmess frag nicht warum
ich stockmess nenne warum warum das ist
hier schon wieder eine Bastelstunde so
45 cm mal 4 eins was 7 cm lang sein soll
nee 7 x 10 cm langepack doch mal die
makra Adventskalender aus und ein cm
langes jetzt brauchen wir unseren
Metallring und natürlich kennen wir
jetzt schon unseren ankerknoten nein ich
habe es in die falsche Richtung gemacht
mein Hirn kann das nicht denken immer
dieses Hin und
[Musik]
Her so jetzt müssen da nur noch die
Holzkugeln rein diese Schnur soll durch
dieses kleine Loch wie soll da noch ein
zweites rein und jetzt nimmt ihr euch
irgend Gegenstand den ihr findet
quetscht es rein oh Schraube
funktioniert tatsächlich sehr gut glaube
ich Kugel 1 ist
drin nee sorry also das geht einfach
nicht
es gibt so nicht ich hab's geschafft ich
sag's euch das also so dürfte das nicht
sein und jetzt das gleiche noch mal mit
den anderen
Kugeln nee das macht keinen Spaß
verstehen sie
[Applaus]
Spaß l mich richtig
verzweifel nichts in meinem Leben hat
mir so wenig Spaß gemacht wie das gerade
zu basteln Ich füh mich richtig
gebrochen verzweifeln sie im Advent
jeden Tag ein bisschen mehr wenn das
nicht gleich super aussieht flipp ich
aus in den Abständen zwischen den beiden
strengen Knoten sie den was
ah
was zwischen den streng
okay
Alter also den packe ich euch definitiv
in die Instagram Verlosung könnt ihr
euch sicher sein das Teil will ich nie
wiedersehen und jetzt ist alles wieder
locker was ich hier so schön festgezogen
hatte das ist hälich so jetzt soll das
auf eine Länge geschnitten
werden und jetzt soll man es noch
auskämen na klar ich kä hier noch mein
marame das ma ich doch gerne hier habt
ihr euer
makrameel ja sieht schon cool aus aber
das war wirklich ein pain in ne s jetzt
bei Türchen Nummer 3 und in Türchen
Nummer 3 natürlich ein Holzring was
machen wir mit diesem Holzring jawoh wir
skippen mal diese Schneeflocke und
machen mal weiter mit der Nummer
4 oh mein Gott eine professionelle
ausbürstungsbürste vorher habe ich
diesen blöden Kamm benutzt aber jetzt
kann ich hier richtig schön ausbürsten
und Fransen
u okay es sieht echt ein bisschen besser
aus zum ausbürsten kommen wir hier
richtig denn wir machen die
Feder einmal 25 cm 11 x 14
cm was machst du hier
zack das war die 25 cm
[Applaus]
Schnur ich bin heute auch irgendwo aber
nicht bei marame jetzt haben wir eine 25
cm Schnur und 11 x 14 cm und coole
Bürste für die Feder und den langen
dingsmittel zusammen so das ein normaler
Knoten das macht man jetzt mit allen
Knoten Knoten
[Musik]
Knoten oh so finde ich das doch auch
schön so kann das doch bleiben sieh
bisschen aus wie so ein Skelett ne aber
nein jetzt Bürsten wir es
aus ehrlich gesagt geht das mit meinem
kam besser als mit der
Bürste seht ihr das und das ist die
Feder schneiden wir jetzt natürlich noch
mal ein bisschen
hübsch wird jetzt eher persönlich als
Blatt als statt Feder bezeichnen aber
gut ja ne ist doch
schön Türchen
Nummer F eine neue schnurfarbe
und eine Holzkugel hat aber wenigstens
ein größeres Loch wir machen jetzt ein
Tannenbaum oder oh nee ein
geschenkeanhänger schnell und dekorativ
schnell finden wir gut einmal 35 cm kein
Problem kriegst du 10 x 15 al ist doch
jetzt schon wieder und 30 cm von dem
Grün ich moderiere das mittlerweile auch
so als ob ich wüsste was ich tue nehm
eine von den schnuren und machen ein
Knoten ja ja und jetzt wieder durch die
Holzkugel und zack das war gar nicht
schwer was euer
Problem so das jetzt einfach da in die
Mitte legen zack das drüber und
handelsüblicher Knoten gar kein Problem
alle Fäden nach unten führen mit einem
wickelknoten etwa was ist denn noch mal
ein
wickelknoten so und dann unter diese
Schnur durch und dann zieht man es
zurück beide Enden abschneiden
fantastisch weiß ich nicht diger Wüsten
sie
ja das ma ich doch
gerne seid ihr nicht schon ganz
aufgeregt und wollt dieses Teil
gewinnen ist aber ganz hübschus ist ein
ganz kleines Paket ein Holzring das
bedeutet nie was Gutes nee das ist zu
kompliziert ein Tannenbaum und da knotet
man sich wirklich den halben Tag ein ab
also wenn man so daran denkt jeden Tag
so eine Geschichte zu machen das kann
ich mir schon richtig gut vorstellen nur
diese holzperlengeschichte die nervt wir
gucken mal erstmal weiter ne Nummer
7 das heißt ja schon wieder gar nichts
Gutes weiß ich nicht muss das ein
glasmkierer und wenn jeder so sein Glas
markiert dann sind ja alle wieder
unmarkiert oder habe ich jetzt ein
Denkfehler das reicht glaube ich mit
einem kleinen Sticker oder so dass man
sein Glas markiert ich sag euch wie es
ist ich werde mir diese perlengeschichte
jetzt einmal sparen das sieht halt auch
nicht aus ne da könnte man sich
vielleicht was anderes überlegen Nummer
ich glaube man zahlt 40 € für ein
bisschen Faden und Holzperlen und
Ringe ein Geschenkanhänger oh das ist
aber cool mit ein ganz wenig Aufwand
macht man dann so ein richtig krasses
Geschenk obwohl das für so ein Geschenk
was man einmal aufmacht ja auch ein
bisschen viel ist ne 8 x
15 und nun machen wir wieder unseren
beliebten ankerknoten dafür ankern wir
das hier einmal rum rein so da wird das
einmal schön reingeankert und so
festgezogen wie ihr nur könnt es ist
doch nicht möglich wieso wieso
funktioniert mein Hirn nicht und einmal
durch ich glaube die Schnur die sie ich
aber mitgegeben haben ist nicht so hoch
also hat nicht so eine Festigkeit wie
anderes makrame seit einer Stunde am
machen und schon wie ein Profi
reden aber eins checke ich nicht ich
zieh die wirklich fest ne und dann wenn
ich mit anderen fertig bin sind die
ersten schon wieder locker geworden guck
mal ich habe ein Stern gemacht Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam
ich liebe
C ich liebe es meine Schnur zu
K ja ihr wisst dass das in der Verlosung
landen wird okay Nummer 9 ihr wisst uh
Nummer 9 ist ein großes Paket Nummer 9
ist das beste Türchen denn das ist meine
Lieblingszahl ach
wirklich wow wir kriegen schon neues
dabei habe ich noch so viel über ach ich
habe mir manche Projekte nicht gemacht
okay verständlich aha ein dreieckiger
Untersetzer dann machen wir doch mal
glatt Nummer ze auf ich kann h ja
wirklich nicht alles machen und ich habe
schon viel mehr gemacht als ich dachte
ein Holzring UI ne makrame Schneeflocke
hier wird nicht gesagt wofür man sie
braucht aber ich denke mal als Deko
eignet sie sich perfekt wird in 11 eine
Holzperle drin sein oder ein Ring bleibt
dran um es zu erfahren nach einer kurzen
Werbeunterbrechung kennen sie sie das
auch sie sind
Spaß ein Haargummi gibt's jetzt ein
marameel Haarschmuck marame
Zopfgummi das ist ausgeflippt ich könnte
hier eigentlich auch so ein bisschen
marame gebrauchen ne der perfekte
blickfun Nummer
12 oh jetzt gibt's ein großes Projekt
schon die dritte Kordel ja das verstehe
ich nicht das ist ja cool so ein
zimtstangenschmuck ne für ein Baum zum Z
ja ich habe keine Zimtstange schade
schade es gab ja schon viele Artenzahlen
darzustellen aber mit dieser Strichliste
das ist schon fies
Ohrringe also ich finde das ja okay wenn
das Metall nicht hier schon so verfärbt
wäre und oxidiert das würde ich mir
niemals ins Ohr stecken schaut euch mal
auch die was ist das denn schaut euch
mal die Ösen an wie unterschiedlich groß
die sind wie unterschiedlich das gebogen
ist sorry ja für 40 € kann man jetzt
nicht viel verlangen aber also einfach
ganz ordentliche Ohrstecker die kann man
ja also das hier kostet ja fast nichts
ich glaub das hat das Team da irgendwie
selber gebogen weil auch dieser
Unterschied ist so krass me es ist ganz
cool sich auch Ohrschmuck damit zu
machen aber nicht mit so ein
Metall 14 ein Holzring ah ja ein
serviertenring mega cool also aber dann
macht man noch mindestens vier oder
mindestens zwei für den Weihnachtstisch
ja gut man soll sich dann halt danach
den Rest selber kaufen hier sind
Holzringe holzchen oh ein Metallring
edler
Taschenanhänger okay so edel sieht der
Taschenanhänger aber auch nicht aus ne
aber zu dem Look ist es dann natürlich
hübsch ich muss nur sagen wenn man dann
mit diesem Adventskalender durch ist
dann ist man ja komplett ausgestattet
mit allen möglichen maame Accessoires D
man diese verrückte
Person und mit diesem Holzring machen
wir jetzt eine große Schneeflocke ja
toll 17 und 17 fühlt sich wieder an nach
Schnur und was soll man mit dieser
Schnur machen ach ja komm also wirklich
das ist doch nur die Feder andersrum
geschnitten jetzt ist es ein Tannenbaum
nee ich habe gelogen ein bisschen anders
geknotet ich sag's euch wie es es ich
habe keinen Bock mehr
18 guck mal es geht doch ein
aufwendigerer Anhänger ach mensch das
ist jetzt ein richtiger schlüssanhänger
hier haben die gegönnt der sieht richtig
cool aus den mache ich weiß n nicht ob
ich den jetzt machen sollte ja das ist
schön und halt ein ordentlicher Anhänger
dazu falls sie vergessen habt es ist
jetzt Nummer 19
dran ist es ein Ring ist es eine
Holzkugel sind Ringe und Holzkugeln u
toll oh nee oh da kriege ich doch schon
wieder Aggressionen wenn ich das das
sind wieder diese gleichen huskugeln und
dieses Mal viermal dass man jeweils zwei
schnuren durch diese Holzkugeln
durchkriegt habe ich noch nicht
verarbeitet Nummer
20 Holzkugel guck mal me frag frag sich
doch immer warum haben manche Tassen
kein Henkel damit ihr euch was aus
makrame machen könnt und so dann die
Tasse haltet der Tassenwärmer sieht
eigentlich aus wie ein Schlüsselanhänger
nur dass er einmal rumgeschnürt wird
kennt ihr die Tricks aus dem
Lebensmittelhandel wenn die Essen
fotografieren aber das nicht wirklich
essen ist noch nie war es so auffällig
wie hier das sieht doch schon nach
Rasierschaum aus das ist kein
Milchschaum das ist also was soll das
sein was ist das 21 und ein Holzring
Leonie guck mal das bekommst an
Weihnachten 22 ich bekomme langsam
Hunger ein Holzring und noch mehr Schnur
bei diesem hier wussten sie selber nicht
mehr wie Sie es nennen sollen deswegen
haben sie es solles Ornament genannt
solles Ornament für den booho
weihnachtsbaau ich hab die ganze Zeit
überlegt wie der Einrichtungsstil heißt
Boho mit marame erfüllt man sich seinen
Boho einrichtungstraum ich war auch mal
so eine Boho Maus aber dann habe ich
mich irgendwie an diesem Look satt
gesehen für die Adventskalender
experience ne das ist ein bisschen
schwach ist vielleicht nicht vielen
wichtig aber mir schon wir kriegen noch
ein Anhänger für noch ein Schlüsselband
jetzt gibt es noch einen Taschenanhänger
allerdings mit einem goldenen Anhänger
und wir kriegen hier schon wieder Silber
also man hätte doch einmal Gold und
einmal Silber machen können wenn die das
schon mit Gold
zeente und jetzt kommen wir zum 24
eigentlich haben wir am 24 gar keine
Zeit zum basteln aber neben dem
Schminken dem ganz machen dem vegan ha
Braten zubereiten finden wir vielleicht
eine ruhige Minute um uns dem letzten
Bastelprojekt zu widmen und dafür
bekommen wir eine gottverdammte
Holzkugel damit machen wir natürlich
einen Weihnachtsengel der
Weihnachtsengel ist quasi das hier nur
mit Flügeln ja jetzt seid ihr ganz
gespannt und wollt wissen wie ich diesen
Kalender finde ne wenn man an den Preis
von 40 € denkt dann ist es ja erstmal
gut das Buch ist für immer verwendbar
das kann man sich jetzt als
weihnachtsbastelbuch in den Schrank
packen und dann kannst du es für dein
Leben lang benutzen die Auswahl der
Accessoires finde ich ein bisschen
schwach ich glaube man hätte da einfach
noch ein bisschen mehr rausholen können
und ja halt also sowas wie dieser
goldene Ring fand ich war ein Highlight
auch wenn dieses Projekt ein pain in the
ass war und ich das auch ein bisschen
verkackt habe ansonsten lernt man hier
wirklich makrame Schritt für Schritt
jeden Tag ein bisschen und ich glaube so
lernt man es auch am besten nicht dass
man sich am Anfang ein riesenprjekt
macht an dem man irgendwie dann nach
zwei Tagen verzweifelt weil man noch
nicht so gut im Kram ist sondern dass
man jeden Tag so ein ganz kleines
Projekt hat und dann ein bisschen was
knotet ein bisschen Gefühl dafür bekommt
wurende Finger kriegt und wenn man
jemand kennt der so eine kleine
bastelmaus oder ein kleiner
bastelmäuserig ist dann ist das bestimmt
richtig nett ich frage mich nur ob 40 €
notwendig waren weil am Ende bastelt man
sich das ja alles selbst für das hier 24
Bastelideen ja so ein Zehner und dann ja
ich weiß nicht wie viel diese Schnuer
sind aber sorry ich habe das Gefühl 30
hätten es auch getan weil man sich das
doch alles selber basteln muss und
diese Teile so Anhänger oder diese
Holzringe die kosten ja fast nichts was
kosten die im bastelan 50 Cent
vielleicht na ja bildet euch eure eigene
Meinung ich fand es hifty fifty stark
angefangen schnell wieder nach unten
wegen der Kugeln dann wieder nach oben
gezogen und irgendwie zum Ende hat sich
das wiederholt und dann hat's wieder
stark nachgelassen aber ich glaube ich
wäre jetzt nicht traurig gewesen wenn
ich den bekommen hätte in dem Sinne bis
zum nächsten mal eure
adventskalenderkönigin Vanessa